[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a science fiction drama film
called finch
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie starts with a brief montage of
earth in ruins a solar flare damaged the
ozone layer 10 years ago causing
temperatures to climb to 150 degrees
fahrenheit planet earth has deteriorated
into a mostly inhospitable wasteland
scorched by uv radiation and vulnerable
to catastrophic weather phenomena finch
one of the few survivors is shown at the
start he is a robotics engineer equipped
with a suit that protects him from the
heat and the uv rays like any other day
he's scavenging for supplies with his
robot dewey when he walks inside a store
his measurements suggest that uv
radiation levels in the area are quite
high meanwhile the robot picks whatever
is left in the store finch is then seen
taking some dog food after leaving he
marks the area so that he can keep track
of the places that he's already
scavenged in the next scene finch
travels through a deserted town that has
been ravaged due to the ozone layer's
depletion the uv rays make it impossible
for people to go outside hence the
majority of the city has been evacuated
suddenly finch's suit emits a warning
that a storm is approaching he spins the
truck around and slams on the
accelerator while the giant storm chases
him luckily he manages to reach his
underground laboratory which was
formerly owned by the firm for which he
worked before the catastrophe hit later
we get to know that finch is dying from
tuberculosis his dog and pal goodyear is
waiting for him at his big house he hugs
and kisses the dog then prepares the
food he found earlier while goodyear
eats finch merely sips on a drink as the
supplies are running out later with the
help of an ai finch uploads basic
instructions on his new project like how
to care for a dog how to do household
chores and so on since finch loves
goodyear more than anything he is
working on creating a highly specialized
robot to care for him after his death
this is sad but it's also the first
movie ever made where it's not the dog
who's going to die finch has been
conducting a lot of studies on uv rays
and radiation exposure later he removes
dewy's eyes and attaches them to his new
robot after turning the robot on he
starts transmitting data to it after a
lot of failed attempts to communicate
the robot finally nods its head
symbolizing that he is understanding
what finch is trying to convey finch is
overjoyed by the reaction from the robot
and the fact that he's made it one step
further he also plays with his dog
believing that he might soon have a new
friend finch then tells the robot to
mention something about himself the
robot says that he has some rules such
as not harming humans but the most
essential rule is that in finch's
absence he must take care of goodyear at
all costs
all of a sudden the power goes out finch
heads out to repair the wind turbine he
connects the cable after which the
lights are restored inside the robot
names himself jeff meanwhile a gigantic
storm is seen coming their way finch
comes back and connects jeff to the
weather station so he can make a
forecast jeff says that four different
storms will approach them in the next 24
hours and they will not be able to avoid
them he also forecasts that it will last
roughly 40 days hearing this finch
believes that they have to leave the
place soon he also presumes san
francisco is their best option finch
then starts to build the robot's full
body after finishing it finch increases
the robot's transfer rate and starts
teaching him how to walk following a bit
of practice jeff successfully starts
walking while finch is happy with the
progress goodyear dislikes the robot and
doesn't trust him at all as the storm
gets nearer finch starts packing all the
essentials and also unplugs jeff's data
transfer at only 72 percent because of
this jeff is not fully developed and
hence acts like a child
finch calls dewey to join them but
forgets that he has removed his eyes
hence he attaches a camera so that he
can finally see again the four then
climb into an rv and start making their
way towards san francisco at the start
of the ride jeff is extremely curious as
he tries to learn everything that finch
does for the time being the group has
successfully managed to evade the storm
they then stop by a deserted town finch
wears the uv protection suit and calls
jeff to join him outside he then starts
teaching jeff basic instructions on how
to scavenge and also about the hazards
of the sun the duo also has a moment of
fun when they pop some popcorn out in
the sun yes that's how bad the sun has
become the fun however soon fades away
when finch notices the storm approaching
them he gathers everyone and tries to
outrun the storm but it eventually
catches up to them finch rushes outside
with jeff and orders him to help tie the
rv with wires after finch gets tired
jeff takes charge and successfully
completes the task finch then gets
inside the rv and secures it soon the
massive tornado hits and all the wires
begin to snap one after another until
only one is remaining luckily the storm
passes and everyone is fine finch
appreciates jeff's good work but is
disappointed to learn that the front
tire of the vehicle is damaged they have
a spare tire but do not have a jack to
lift the vehicle however jeff simply
lifts the vehicle himself using his
sheer strength and tells finch to change
the tire the next morning jeff attempts
to communicate with goodyear saying that
he is trying to learn the dog's language
but finch wakes up and makes him
understand that it will take some time
for him and goodyear to be on good terms
later that day a board points out that
san francisco is
1522 miles away
finch is stumped when jeff asks him to
explain the notion of trust so he just
shares his own life story he mentions
how he alone solved a software problem
during a project but gave credit to the
whole team in this way he was able to
win their trust as he tells the story
finch's health continues to deteriorate
they then stop at a restaurant where
finch vomits blood realizing that he
doesn't have much time left finch takes
goodyear inside the restaurant and
starts playing with him meanwhile jeff
is toying with the rv he puts on songs
while he tries to drive because of his
clumsiness he lets go of the handbrake
and the rv hits a car when finch
confronts jeff he acts all innocent he
then reverses the rv only to crash it
again a furious finch demonstrates what
happens to his skin when he steps into
the sunlight he then screams at jeff
telling him that his only job is to take
care of goodyear after they leave the
restaurant finch decides to teach jeff
how to drive at first jeff is clumsy as
usual but he soon gets the hang of it
and starts driving smoothly finch is
pleased by this but the doggo remains
skeptical at night they stop by the road
to camp there the beautiful northern
lights can be seen as the ozone layer is
no longer present jeff suggests that
they could drive at night mentioning
that daylight is hazardous however finch
teaches him that hungry people approach
at night and it's dangerous in the
morning finch vomits blood and is also
shivering jeff takes good care of him
asking if he should call the doctor
after that they continue their journey
when they arrive in a major city jeff
wakes dewey and the duo head out to
scavenge for supplies they come across a
hospital which looks looted but jeff has
yet to learn that so he continues his
way inside when finch wakes up he
discovers that both the robots are
missing he knows that trouble lies ahead
so despite being extremely weak he suits
up and sets off to find jeff and dewey
someone is watching him from the shadows
upstairs jeff is delighted to find food
medicine and even a fancy jacket for
himself meanwhile dewey finds some
snacks but fails to notice a bear trap
near it as he reaches for the snacks the
bear trap rips him apart after a
distraught finch finds him he apologizes
and turns off his power
dewey wasn't the favorite anyway
soon finch hears a rumbling sound and
finds jeff as well finch stresses that
they cannot stay in the place any longer
as it is not safe for them both of them
then make a run for it but finch is
barely managing to stay on his feet when
they reach their rv they immediately
speed away but a vehicle starts
following them after traveling a
distance finch hands over the steering
to jeff telling him not to make any
mistakes from now on he also notices the
car still following them they turn off
the headlights as jeff is able to see in
the dark while the mystery car still
pursues them finch suggests jeff to step
on the accelerator and speed up as they
are driving into a storm finch grabs the
wheel and steers it off the road he
intends to use the underpass instead
despite jeff trying his best to explain
that the height of the rv is higher than
the underpass finch does not listen and
eventually it crashes and the rv's solar
panels are destroyed after the crash
jeff uses his strength to push the rv
inside the car that was following them
approaches however it stops for a moment
and then drives away once he's confident
that the people have gone finch rushes
outside and discovers that all of their
solar panels have been damaged he blames
himself for his poor judgment and also
mentions that he cannot repair it jeff
assures him that he can take them to san
francisco but finch snaps at him to stop
talking a furious finch then returns to
the vehicle while jeff stands outside in
the rain after a little snooping jeff
comes inside and tells finch that he
thinks they'll make it to the golden
gate bridge in san francisco meanwhile
finch shares another story and relates
why he doesn't trust people and how he
discovered goodyear in a bag he mentions
that goodyear was terrified and alone
and how he promised to protect him at
any cost finch adds that hunger can turn
any good human being into a killer but
it turned finch into a coward as he kept
hiding while some young boys killed a
young girl and her mother in a
supermarket the next morning another
road sign points out that it is 480
miles to san francisco jeff is on the
wheel while a weak finch rests suddenly
jeff notices a butterfly on the
windshield he pulls over awakens finch
and points to the butterfly finch gets
up and stretches his hand out only to
find it unaffected by the sunlight he
then steps outside and feels the sun the
uv radiation has decreased to the point
where it is no longer a threat i'm no
scientist but this seems like
he sees a flower and another butterfly
and laughs heartily as they continue
their journey they pass flowering planes
later finch gets dressed and they decide
to have a picnic in the sun something he
hasn't done in over a decade finch then
shares some more memories of his past
while wishing that he could make more of
his life hearing this jeff excitedly
gets up and explains that if they leave
now they will reach the golden gate
bridge in about 18 hours however finch
says that he can't make it a saturn to
jeff then promises to take care of
goodyear when he's gone after that finch
brings out goodyear's ball and the two
engage in a game of fetch he then hands
the ball to jeff and explains that this
is one of the first stages in creating
trust with a dog the two then have a
brief moment of fun before suddenly
finch starts coughing up blood his white
suit is now covered in blood when jeff
asks if he can help him finch responds
that he has already done so he then
shakes jeff's hand and they hug here
jeff is visibly upset and we can see
that he has emotions too
jeff then assists finch into the rv
where he lies down goodyear consoles
finch while jeff packs their belongings
finch pats his beloved buddy on the back
one more time before passing away the
two then burn finch on the planes along
with his uv suit after they are done
mourning jeff carries on finch's daily
routine and feeds the dog
later they play fetch again with jeff
goodyear starts to feel safe and begins
to change
jeff also feels that goodyear is now his
responsibility and the two set off again
he befriends goodyear who finally
embraces him when they finally arrive at
the golden gate bridge jeff constructs a
memorial for finch there they find
several messages left by people for
their loved ones letting them know where
they can be found this concludes that
there are more survivors with the
possibility of family members being
reunited in the final scene jeff sticks
his drawing of finch goodyear and
himself on the fence the two of them
then leave for somewhere new subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching